cada día en los últimos 18 años una
media de 20 niños han sido asesinados o
mutilados en medio de Las Guerras en
todo el mundo la ONU ha verificado
315.000 violaciones graves contra
Menores en conflictos de 2015 las cifras
forman parte de un abrumadora informe de
unicef que muestra el alcance del
impacto de la guerra y los conflictos en
los niños la guerra es algo terrible
pero la guerra es cosa de adultos y los
adultos deben como mínimo proteger a los
niños en el transcurso de los conflictos
el informe desglosa las violaciones en
categorías incluidos los niños muertos o
mutilados los reclutados por las fuerzas
armadas los secuestrados y los sometidos
a violencia sexual y lo que es aún más
alarmante solo se trata de los casos
verificados por lo que la cifra real es
probablemente mucho mayor mientras los
líderes se reúnen en oslo para debatir
sobre la protección de la infancia
unicef instala los gobiernos a dar un
paso adelante y asumir nuevos
compromisos Ah creo que es importante
que como comunidad internacional digamos
que no la impunidad que pensamos que
estas personas son responsables en lo
que hacen que no es inevitable que esto
ocurra en la guerra sino que ocurre
porque la gente cree que puede salirse
con la suya y no sabe lo que hace y creo
que debemos intentar que rindan cuentas
la magnitud de los riesgos a los que se
enfrentan los niños en las zonas de
conflicto no se corresponde con la
financiación disponible un análisis
encargado por unicef predice un déficit
de mil millones de dólares para 2026
financiación necesaria para apoyar
servicios críticos como la reunificación
familiar el apoyo a la Salud Mental y la
prevención de reclutamiento por parte de
grupos armados